hey a president Trump expecting to
unload on 2020 Democrats tonight in Ohio
you're looking live in Cincinnati where
I'm splitting the screen with that live
event where just over an hour from now
the president will hold a keep America
great rally before leaving the White
House trumpeting the candidates by the
way about two hours ago in a possible
preview of his speech Warren sometimes
referred to as Pocahontas with her pony
try at an ancestry that she didn't have
it's possible I have to run against her
but everything she did was a fraud I
think that Kamala did not do well last
night I think that I think Biden did
okay you came through he came limping
through as they say about slippy Joe he
lived right through it it's really
boiling down to four or five of them so
what role will the two night debate
extravaganza have in tonight's speech
Dana Perino what do you think how are
you different from two weeks ago I think
that the president will play as Greatest
Hits but not initially but at some point
he's going to go through and he'll
probably go down the line of the
candidates you might not be able to
mention all twenty of them but he'll
he'll hit the top ones I think it's
really smart timing the campaign is to
schedule this rally on the night after
the debate so it's like okay you got two
nights of three hours each of those
Democrats and now the president's gonna
come in it because this is a contrast
election right it's a choice between
President Trump and whoever from that
stage or elsewhere emerges as the
nominee the other thing is just look at
the contrast the Democrats are in
Michigan they have this opportunity to
talk to voters in Michigan a state that
they lost by an inch and that they
desperately need to win back in 2020 and
they are out liberally in each other all
the way now President Trump by contrast
he's going to Ohio no Republicans ever
won an election without Ohio he won by
nine points he's leaving nothing to
chance he's gonna go to Ohio I bet he
brings up Vice President Biden's
comments last night towards the end kind
of a throwaway comment then he was gonna
get rid of fossil fuels bring that up in
Ohio see how that goes it wasn't just
him that brought that up I think
everyone agreed within 10 years gonna
get rid of all fossil fuels especially
in a place that night I believe is run
by the car industry it's kind of
interest
I think the present gotta be a little at
a loss because he had nine people
killing Barack Obama that's what he was
doing so now does he even bother talking
about Obamacare being bad because
everyone agrees it's bad now right are
you asking me a question in a way okay
he was embedding his I think that they
should initiate some chants yes and I
think you're gonna see two worlds like
you've said okay
on one hand you're gonna have prosperity
peace and jobs and on the other hand
you're gonna have the feral apocalypse
that's the way the media will present it
and you will be able to see how obvious
a delusion that is right now as Juan has
shown the media is suffering from ORD
obsessive race disorder everywhere they
look it's race race rate so if he
criticizes anybody of color it's over
it's over right and that's what Don jr.
was saying today Medicare for all
decriminalize the border those things
will what come up and decided an
exaggeration that's what we heard for
the last two nights one right you know I
just I mean to me I think that what Dana
said is on target this is just smart to
get the president out right after the
Democrats have dominated the airwaves
for two nights right and try to get his
message up but you know I think he's got
to be real careful you saw what happened
at the last rally with that Senator Bakk
and all that night it didn't help him
didn't help him with Republicans even
and then tonight I mean he's not gonna
talk about North Korea firing missiles
again he's not gonna talk about feeling
trade talks with China and increase my
production I think I don't think he's
gonna get angry at your own Powell the
Fed Reserve Chairman you know what are
we gonna you know so we talked about all
these failures those problems I just
don't think so folks I don't I think
it's more likely he tries to go after
Biden pocahontas you know I just don't
you to white people want you just
disrupt your points go ahead yeah I
think the people attending tonight's
rally you know they're from Ohio
Kentucky and Indiana so a hundred
percent he's going to
lean into Biden and everyone else's
comments about you know phasing out coal
and fracking etc and his reelect team
ran with that hard last night right we
saw that on Twitter they immediately
pounced on that and I also think that we
talked a little bit about this yesterday
but the the Democratic Party is 100%
alienating a lot of those voters who
have been powering our country for
decades and they are making them seem
like they are part of the problem and so
Trump will likely pounce on that too the
thing is he's got to play a perfect game
Dana because one thing one chance
dominated a 90-minute speech so he's got
to do things maybe that are out of his
control question if he hears send them
back or some type of chance if your
trunk do you not step back do you step
forward go we don't want to hear that do
you or do you Trump just say I can't I
don't know what I might do no no what do
you think he would I don't know I'll
have to see I really don't know oh yeah
prove the line remember cuz percent for
for locker up he like laughed and kind
of egged it on then the second time
would send her back he was like okay no
and so now after that back no that's so
I don't know I think we'll have to see
it's very exciting and well it could be
that no one chance ever now they
shouldn't leave it to chance or chance
chance see socialists could show up for
the rally some interruptions